I can't believe someone finally had the
genius idea of summer camp for adults
camp recharge is the best a full digital
detox no cell phone no email no
distractions no Twitter no Instagram oh
Jesus
I don't think my body can handle being
away from technology like this are you
okay yeah yeah I'll be fine once the
partying starts what are you talking
about we've been partying since we got
here are you serious I'm out of control
right now did you see me jump up on the
table this morning here a breakfast
acapella sing-along of the duck tales
theme song is not a party no no one is
singing I could have sworn I heard duck
tails maybe it was coming from the ropes
course catch you guys later life is like
a hurricane oh my god what is this place
Geir life-or-death question yes after
much deliberation I am doing the talent
show tonight know what why could I not
find them at most a table at breakfast
this morning I tasted like every carafe
and it was all just orange juice there
wasn't one Quinn there's no alcohol
allowed at camp recharge Oh Quinn oh my
god Quinn Quinn Quinn
Oh bro that was weird what what just
happened you passed out after I told you
there was no alcohol it's all coming
which is what I love about this weekend
my body must have knocked me out as a
defense mechanism how could you not tell
me about this having to turn our
cellphones in when we checked in was bad
enough hey pre charge isn't just about
camp activities into Stata it's about
redefining how to have fun no no I can't
hold it anymore I'm doing it I'm sorry
Garrett oh my god yes I'm just I'm
literally just strolling right now what
are you doing how did you get that oh
yeah I snuck into the device lockdown
tent last night but you could get us
kicked out for that oh what's going on
so much is happening so this morning I
saw Kelsey give Dylan a friendship
bracelet after we namaste at dawn Yoga
sick my post mate some alcohol put it
away Quinn
whoa Kelsey and Dylan ki SSI Angie I
know Freddy spaghetti but Bennet
finger-painting Dylan move from sitting
next to Kelsey to sharing paints with
Rilo but Rilo told me last night we were
making s'mores that her divorce papers
are still being processed but Dylan
definitely hasn't told Rilo about his
reverse force ectomy and wanting to
finally try for a family so much drama
and who knows what's gonna happen at the
talent show tonight it's a powder keg
order confirmed
well eta five minutes you're gonna
perform Freddy spaghetti wait okay I'm
sorry Garrett you're Freddy spaghetti
that's right and I'm butternut y'all
gave each other nicknames last night
during cabins story circle Freddy your
cabin story was so funny
I think I'll cancel my subscription
please wait what I don't get it what
subscription of what uh it's kind of
this big mantova cabinet Rough Riders
would get 90s pop culture reverence
flash mob first of 50 points wins oh
heck yeah I love these yeah oh my god
it's like I'm stuck inside of a BuzzFeed
listicle right now I'm so in cowabunga
three points for killer turtles
reference ready to buy mine hold is that
a WMD are you holding a WMD what
wireless mobile device
seriously camper I cannot believe he's
heavily broken this is just like when
Lisa turtle sprains our ankle and Saved
by the Bell episode 1 season 2 title
dancing to the max yeah nineties ten
points oh quit calling ambulance care I
don't understand how would I just call
an ambulance like send a courier pigeon
phone who the photo you're here I think
it would be really unhealthy if you
broke your digital detox
he's right Freddie camp recharge is a
zero tolerance policy you make that call
you're never coming back and I want you
back great reference point this is a
camper tunity will gather materials and
build a splint it should only take a few
hours
ah I'm gonna handle a fireball delivery
for Quinn technology wins make the call
Oh bro actually it like literally just
died
hey guys GERD here I'm making a speedy
recovery thanks to technology please
share your worst summer camp stories in
the comments below also Quinn was
totally right the dopamine kick of
reading comments online is way better
than any experience I've had outdoors